foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
check check check dude I don't know why
that sorry guys I don't know why the
music just
randomly does that sometimes
should be playing through the playlists
sorry it was so quiet for a bit
your speakers are not broken mic check
mic check mic check
good evening ladies and gentlemen
good evening to some of you good morning
to some of you good afternoon some of
you
the stream's current bitrate is lower
than the recommended we recommend that
you use an audio stream oh great
I tell you man
they just do not want you to stream on
multiple platforms they just do not want
you to do it
for those who don't know we streamed
this morning over on Twitch some Harry
Potter and Goblet of Fire
one of the worst of the Harry Potter
video games
hadn't streamed over there in a while
and thought you know what let's just
let's go over there and stream for a
little bit
but now it just makes it so difficult to
switch back and forth like all of my
hopefully the audio sounds okay
it's telling me that it's not the right
bit rate but hopefully we're good
welcome everyone hello and welcome good
evening
all right I'm not feeling this one I
need something a little bit more
upbeat
oh actually you know what
you know what I've got one
I've got one
how about this
how about this one
[Music]
reading the books again to prepare nice
105 A.M
how's everybody doing
everybody have a happy New Year
start to the New Year anyway
hey devil Blom member for two months old
guys yeah look
you see how we we changed up the setup
again the tree's gone
[Music]
now the hammer
is in easily
easy distance for me to reach
welcome new members of house rack and
tour thank you guys for being here Elwyn
with the five gifted no three no four no
four no streamlabs stream elements can't
keep up
they can't keep up thank you so much
Ellen for the gift of memberships
guys uh if you just got a gift a
membership from Elwyn
make sure you think you're there in the
chat and you also get access to some
pretty slick emotes if I do say so
myself special Discord roll and you also
get to see me hold up the hammer of Thor
and to welcome you as an official member
of House raconteur
all right let's see who got those gifted
memberships ZZ or no ZZ Shire renewed a
membership thank you so much ZZ
and then we had Elwyn gifting one nope
okay Ellen gifted one I don't know why
it shows up like that sometimes
uh Draco got one of the gifteds let's go
devrel Gabe and then ZZ shirer
and welcome to the new Subs as well see
a couple of new people subscribing to
the channel
welcome welcome guys
[Music]
I don't like that Morgana fell over
how's it going Rizzo welcome
[Music]
uh did you ever analyze the last
last room no so we're gonna try and
tackle that tonight yeah so we've done
the first section made a video on that
we did a live stream on the combat
section video on that is coming this
week
and then we'll see how much time we have
tonight but I also plan to uh yeah cover
that as well
and David a member for three months
thank you so much David
yet another member of House rack and
tour
wait did David's go in oh man see I tell
you when you
when you switch back and forth between
streaming on Twitch streaming on YouTube
I've had to reset so many of my settings
I actually hit go live tonight and I was
still logged into my twitch on OBS so it
went live for a second over there I had
to go and
cancel that really quick and then fire
up the live here instead
all right let's see who's in the house
tonight let's see who is in the house
we're gonna run down the list shout out
everyone
all right we got Adam here
ether is back both members of house
tracking tour Antoine is back with us
welcome Antoine Ashley atomic dudman
asriel
uh b-i-q-u-e beak
thank you so much for becoming or for
being a member of House Dragon tour
black star love we got blue moon and
boss hyper both channel members right
there Carmine official cheetah boy
welcome thank you all for being here
uh chausic chocic Chas UC member of
House Dragon tour as well welcome
Christian labels Christopher Frank thank
you guys for being here Clint member of
House racquet tour is here cubby Man Dan
oh and then we got oh oh wow okay big
long list of house wrecking tour members
Right Here Deborah wizard devil Blom Dr
sherbet in the house
Dustin quists and then Elwyn
all members of house tracking tour right
there Frost Nova rank one Gigi is a
lobster gravity's reach both members of
house rack into it right there how's it
going guys
Jacob Jeffrey Jenny hey I saw Jenny
earlier in our uh in our goblet of fire
gameplay stream
welcome back Jenny we got Jesse we got
Joel We got JP raven fire all members of
house wrecking tour right there uh Kayla
king of games welcome
all right let's go back to the other one
now
Chris up and puff welcome back Chris
how's it going Christy is here tonight
Christie hope everything went well with
the move
Christie has been trying to move for a
while now and just kept getting
stumbling blocks roadblocks along the
way uh Lauren D those last three all
members of house wrecking tour uh little
lady
then we got Magicka marvolo Ravenclaw
moonly Noob what's up Noob welcome back
Nathan fox nightbot in the house Nikki
25 all those members of house record
tour right there thank you guys for
being here Nokes Panda plays games
what's up Panda by the way guys Panda
always
over in the Discord
like the one of the go-to people for
getting getting screenshots of Hogwarts
Legacy we have a Hogwarts Legacy photo
mode section Panda always good about
uploading some new ones in there we got
Pete pineapple Sam member of housewreck
into it right there Port Mantella 293
Professor Baxter
radar back-to-back channel members right
there uh Randall Denson rebelclaw Tyrell
what's up Ravenclaw Terrell saw you in
the twitch live stream earlier this
morning as well
uh Rhett Mitchell Rizzo SF okara Shadow
Cloud clouds for
then we got Shadow guided Shadow guide
was also there this morning Sharon Cruz
silver saw silver there as well three
channel members in a row right there
then we got just just Slytherin just
plain old Slytherin in the house
welcome Slytherin star Geezer Tim here
with us tonight
member of House racket tour how's it
going Tim hope you're doing well then we
got t g d j f b d the Fallen Vol Rath
Ultra Blue Jr unsung hero William Brad
Seth William Hitchens Xena 838 yawg ZZ
shirer and then
zutara babe
zero nine
zutara told me in an email how to
pronounce it guys guitar won one of our
giveaways on the Christmas live stream
and in the email told me this is how
it's pronounced and so I was like I've
got to remember
gotta remember
it's uh inspired by avatar Last
Airbender
so I think it's Zuko and Katara right a
combination
to give you zutara and then babe zero
nine I like it it works alright guys if
I missed you sorry went through all of
the people that were
participants listed
in the Stream
[Music]
yo already at 100 likes oh my goodness
already at 100 likes you know what that
means
not used to your name with an American
accent ah Sharon Cruz
so how
I'm trying to think of how
cause that's a pretty like Sharon and
Cruz pretty common
trying to think of how else it would be
pronounced
and I'm failing
all I can hear is like the old school
Ozzy Osbourne Sharon
Sharon
that's all I can think of I'm gonna try
to think of a different way
team puff more with a British act okay
oh so kind of like Ozzy Sharon Sharon
Sharon Sharon
you get that a lot
oh man too funny too funny
too funny
Dustin
getting us started with a ten dollar
Super Chat
thank you so much Dustin is considering
this game already one of the greatest
games of all time too much hype
I I I think that might qualify Dustin I
don't know I mean I think that might be
teetering a little bit on the verge of
that
a little bit on the verge
oh man we're gonna talk we're gonna talk
about hype tonight you guys
we're gonna talk a lot about hype hype
and expectations
I mean and I'll just tell you from the
beginning dude I'm like I I love hype I
do
I do we'll break it down and just like
you know because they're they're
advantages to being
I don't think you ever want to be
blindly
hyped about something right like just
totally
you just completely over the moon for it
when you haven't seen anything
but then there are times when I think
the hype is reasonable and I think
certain people like it's just different
personalities man like
if you're somebody who prefers like I
don't want to get let down then yeah the
best way is to go in with have your
expectations like way down here right
then you can be disappointed
for the most part that's not how I go
through life
for the most part that's not how to go
through life but we're going to talk
more about it gonna talk a lot more
about it Draco with a super chat as well
Draco thank you for the support my
friend Dustin simple answer is no not
too much hype
if you guys missed the first question
Dustin was is considering this game
already one of the greatest games of all
time too much hype
I'll let you guys be the judge I'll let
you be the judge
oh and that does remind me I did want to
start
I'm going to start a poll question right
now because I'm really curious to see
their reaction on this okay
I'm not just gonna ask is there too much
hype what I want to ask is
if Hogwarts Legacy
doesn't live up to your expectations
will you regret hyping it up
and I'm asking that question very
intentionally because it really gets at
the Crux of the issue for me so here it
is again if Hogwarts Legacy doesn't live
up to your expectations your personal
expectations will you regret hyping it
up yes I will have wasted my time
or I will
feel like oh man you can't you can't the
responses are so short
I'm just gonna say yes
um I don't want to say wasted my time
but like
not a I don't know how to say it I'm
just gonna say yes but then for the no
I want to add a qualifier of
I enjoyed
the journey
no I will still ah I can't fit it
or no no how about this no
it's about the journey
ask I have a feeling I know this is
gonna go but I want to ask it anyway
I'm gonna ask it anyway
I think this is gonna be really
interesting like that response from Moon
Lily right there that's what I want to
hear from you guys because
I don't want anybody to feel like
if you have if you have cautious if you
have skepticism about that game you're
welcome here if you have concerns about
the game you're welcome here and you're
welcome to mention them in the chat
if you think it's going to be the
greatest game of all time as Dustin here
just said with a super chat guess what
you're welcome here too uh but Moon
Lily's comment for anybody who mentioned
missed it I'm all for the hype but I
also keep in mind that problems exist
and can happen so I try not to let my
emotions dictate my actions and
responses especially if the devs are
willing to fix issues
Nico says even if the game bombs talking
with this community has been worth the
time and hype
yo welcome to the new subscribers and
the or division in the house what is up
or division thanks so much for the Super
Chat no because the journey up to this
point has been absolutely amazing and
joyful this community has grown stronger
and epic cheers mate cheers to you as
well or division thank you for being
here hanging out dude it's crazy I can't
believe how close we are man I can't
believe how close we are
officially in 2023 I mean pretty close
to being able to say one month away
one month away
Gabe says no because of channels like
you and the community thank you Gabe
yeah so all of this um
all of this came about
if you guys follow me on Twitter you
already saw this so
actually you know what let's go ahead
let's go ahead and uh let me switch the
scenes here
let's just Dive Right into this
discussion
I had a feeling people were itching to
talk about this one James said people
had already been talking about this
video
on his Discord
and uh I put out the tweet and actually
I just put up the video and started
getting some comments right away for
people like what are you kidding me with
this title
I'm like calm down calm down calm down
it's a question it's a question
all right so
uh Ryan said it's hard enough living a
balanced enough life
I could watch you and James play it
instead of playing it myself and be
entertained enough to be happy
Dustin we've seen so much from the
Showcase in post I feel it's been a lot
better than what CD projekt Red did
leading up to cyberpunk
uh Simeon says no game will be God of
War Ragnarok for me but the community is
a bright spot yeah see guy that's all
all perspectives are welcome here I'm I
really it was so anxious and curious to
hear what you guys think about this
um mainly because
of something that Luke says here toward
the end of his video expecto go what is
up my friend we were just talking about
you
just talking about you
thank you so much expect to go for
continuing to support the channel then
we had Dr sherbet oh wait hold on expect
to go
another member of house where I can tour
you guys already know him if you haven't
already
check out his Hogwarts Legacy videos
another great great Wizarding World
content creator uh then we had Dr
sherbet with a super chat Dr Sherbert
thank you my friend no as even if it
does fail I would have made friends here
and that is was most important P.S
thanks again for the merch it's great ah
nice Dr sherbet did it already come in
no way it got there yet did it get there
that quick
either way
thank you man hope you hope you enjoy it
and then also uh Stephen with a super
chat I will love this game no matter
what because I know they will continue
to work on it if it needs it my hype has
been kept in check so I believe it will
be worth it I can't wait to play Steven
thank you so much for your perspective
dude I I love hearing
you know it's this has been this game
has been so fascinating because it was
first it was just a rumor right and then
it was okay this is actually happening
and then it was just like we know
nothing so we're out here
we're excited we're eager we want to
know more
so like to me that I mean that qualifies
as hype but
that's not a bad thing right it's not a
bad thing to be excited about the
potential of something the possibility
of something all right so what spurred
this though for me is this video from
Luke Stevens here so Luke is a
very in-depth YouTuber I mean you go to
his channel and look at some of his
videos and I mean this guy like he does
a fantastic job of really just drilling
down into
what makes a game what it is right pros
and cons like look at this right here he
has a this is over a three hour three
and a half hour video
an ultimate critique of the Batman
Arkham series over three million views
I mean so these are really in-depth
videos now he does have some shorter
ones too like this this uh Hogwarts one
is a bit shorter but then he has this
God of War one right here over four
hours I mean so anytime he puts out a
video
you know he's gonna put he puts a lot of
thought into it
and he himself admits like that's what's
the beginning is about here he admits
he's a Harry Potter fan he's got the the
castle here in the back in the
background
so if you haven't seen this video I
definitely think it's worth everyone
checking out I do I think it's uh
if nothing more it gives you an
interesting perspective
to consider maybe what some of the
people who haven't he's made a couple
videos on Hogwarts Legacy but I don't
think even he would say that he's
followed it as closely as a lot of us
have like following it for every little
detail
but I think it's definitely worth
watching
just so you can kind of see you know
what what some other people are saying
and get another get another perspective
on the game
all right and as we do that I want to
get let's see let me mute this music
here
and then let's go with the fireplaces
[Music]
and I want to go back to the default
view I want to Loop the playlist
we're just gonna have this kind of going
here in the background
oh wait before I do that though
I need another tab
Dustin are you kidding me my friend
Dustin with a 20 Super Chat
Dustin man always showing crazy love and
support for the Stream
always showing crazy love and support
even if the story in side quests are
subpar there is still the carrying of
magical creatures exploration Community
potential for exciting DLC and or sequel
to improve upon any shortcomings
good points Dustin good points
so as I was kind of starting to touch on
there
I see there are really two different
types of hype in my mind
there's hype that's like excitement for
potential
which is what I was just talking about
there before we even knew like anything
about the game when it was just a rumor
like yeah I'm gonna be excited I'm gonna
be hyped for that right
knowing very little
just being a fan of the series I mean
being a fan of the Wizarding World
wanting an RPG story driven like game
set in that world for years I'm gonna be
like quote unquote hyped right
I think where it starts to become an
issue is when you get into like blind
hype or basing your hype on
like when when hype and expectations
start to blur a little bit
and they're always going to have some
overlap but there's someone who
responded on Twitter
I'm gonna shout them out because it was
a really
it was a good way of looking at it
let's see here
pika pi nine
I think they watch the stream a lot so
they might be here
I'm not sure what their name is on here
though
oh where did it go where did your reply
go I just had it
I just had it
here it is here it is here it is so what
Pinkie Pie said was uh in regards to
Luke's video he provided a fresh look on
things but I literally cannot get say my
hype hype is way different from
expectations my expectations only come
from what they've shown in their
gameplay and trailers there's a
difference between being hyped about a
game that you've been waiting for your
entire life and expecting unrealistic
things I love watching this video but I
do not think someone should throw their
hype away because it might get tangled
in your expectations for the game
so looking at it and I kind of agree
right like I have my excitement I have
like my dream
of what Hogwarts Legacy could be like my
10 out of 10 dream
then I have my expectations
and if it exceeds those expectations
great if it doesn't
even if it doesn't that's what my poll
question is really trying to get at
there
tasty meatballs with a super chat oh man
this one's got this one's got you guys
talking and Shadow guided with a super
chat as well Shadow guided people make
it 4 out of 10 gameplay will add to it
all
wait what people make it 410 gameplay
we'll add to it all I'm not sure what
you meant there Shadow guided
you talking about mods Maybe
talking about mods potentially
if you I'll try to catch your comment in
the chat uh Shadow guided if you wanna
if you want to clarify but then we also
had tasty meatballs with a super chat
Avalanche seems extremely passionate for
the game definitely my most anticipated
game for this year but I think curbing
hype is always healthy I'm just sad
quidditch didn't make the cut
so yeah I mean let's let's get into what
what Luke talks about here
I thought about doing a video on this
and I was like no I I could do a video
on it but this one I I want to get I
want to get this live feedback I want to
get reaction from you guys too so he
starts off talking about how he's a fan
of the Wizarding World he's a fan of
Harry Potter you see it in his
background there and he talks about the
good I mean he talks about how the world
looks phenomenal he talks about how the
castle looks very well done
the recreation of Hogwarts and he does
talk about the passion for the
developers that's what made me think of
it when you said that tasty meatballs
he talks about the passion for the
developers which we have talked at
length about here
admits that it looks it looks awesome
but then where it starts to get inch I
think where what's really so interesting
about his video is this whole question
of hype and expectations he said in the
video that he tries to avoid falling
victim to this Loop of disappointment in
the gaming industry when it doesn't live
up to your expectations
now we've talked
far more than I want to talk about
cyberpunk over here because wizard for
whatever reason anytime people hype a
game everyone just has to bring up
cyberpunk because it was a game that was
endlessly hyped and looked forward to by
fans and then I haven't even played it
so I don't know but to a lot of people
did not live up to expectations
it always frustrates me because it's
like it's like an Apple Store oranges
comparison in my mind
but it's still gonna happen right so
people bring that up this idea that
and so that burned some people that
burned a lot of people and so now as a
result of that they're like okay I'm
just gonna keep my expectations here I'm
not gonna get hyped I'm gonna I'm gonna
stay low down here and to those people I
say that's fine that's that's great like
I have no problem with it whatsoever
but then also like what my channel has
really been all about and I think James
would say the same thing for his channel
it's like when I'm excited about
something
I want to share it with other people
right
and then as a result of that a lot of
you guys
are also excited you see some of the
same things I do we disagree on some
things we've already seen in the chat
here we've we've had some you know
some healthy disagreements here already
some different perspectives on hype
keeping things in check that sort of
thing even some people donating saying
they're keeping their hype and
expectations in check yet they're still
here hanging out watching the Hogwarts
Legacy live stream I think that's great
but I've always viewed my channel as
really a place where
if you're excited about this this is a
place you can come and be excited you
know
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with that I don't a noisy boy with a
super chat as well are you going to live
stream the final moments of Hogwarts
Legacy before it's official release like
a New Year's countdown I think I think
so noisy boy yeah we talked about that a
little bit on our last live stream
I think so I think it'd be fun to
revisit a lot of my old Hogwarts Legacy
videos in the lead up
so maybe start the stream this is not
official yet but I'm thinking like you
know start maybe 6 p.m
Eastern or so 7 P.M Eastern somewhere in
there and then uh like slowly as we
count up to midnight
but then Nico went back and checked for
me guys
insane Nico went back and checked
because I was like oh dude what if we
re-watched all of our Hogwarts Legacy
videos all of our Hogwarts Legacy videos
and here's what Nico said fun fact if
you were to re-watch all of your
Hogwarts Legacy related videos you would
need
982 minutes or
16.3 hours
[Music]
why is the Ravenclaw one so loud I don't
know
why is Ravenclaw so loud
16.3 hours of videos there you go
there you go
[Music]
so don't think we can do that don't
think we can do that oh yeah somebody
said look at the poll
let me see oh no I didn't mean to stop
that though
uh this one
if Hogwarts Legacy so we asked a poll
question guys already over 300 votes if
you didn't get your vote in I'm gonna
leave it up for a little bit longer if
Hogwarts likes he doesn't live up to
your expectations will you regret hyping
it up 19 said yes
81 said no it's about the journey and
that's where I fall guys that's where I
fall so another one of my favorite
YouTubers Ali abdall he's like a
productivity YouTuber
interviews a lot of great people
interesting people thought provoking
people on his podcast
and we're obviously we're taking it
we're taking it to a different area here
but he interviews a guy who wrote this
book called
I think I think it's called Hold on let
me look it up here make sure I get it
right
it's called the happiness
project I believe
nope that's not it it's not the
Happiness Project
hold on I remember his name though
solve for happy that's it
solve for happy engineer your path to
Joy now when he's talking about like
genuine happiness in this book not like
the dopamine reaction of enjoying a
video game
but I thought it's interesting that he
says he has this equation that's like
this is hap happiness equals event minus
expectation
so like
if you have very low expectations on and
then something exceeds it of course
you're gonna you'll be like wow you know
I'm genuinely
excited by that
and then the inverse of that would be oh
if you have your expectations way up
here and then it you know I mean we all
do this right like you're maybe there's
a restaurant you're really excited about
right or you can't wait to get this I
don't know ice cream sundae whatever it
may be
and then the moment comes and it's like
the machine's broke or it's not as good
as you thought it was gonna be right
and it's like oh you know it's
disappointing
but I think it's it's all about your own
personality I feel like but what anyway
to get back to that book what he ends up
arguing is that
you know if you only wanted to optimize
for like pure you just want to be happy
every day then you would start every day
with just an expectation of zero right
it's like you're just expecting nothing
to go right which also could have its
own sort of negative connotations right
but what he argues is that
it's like you want that healthy balance
right
realistic expectations
and so for me like thinking about that
analogy
and thinking about your guys's response
in the poll here the fact that so many
of you agree it's about like this this
journey that we're on together
I consider all of this I consider the
hype I consider the lead up I consider
that part of the event quote unquote
right
and I've said like I've been on record
saying like I personally have seen
enough to for Hogwarts I see to be
excited and hyped about it that I don't
feel like it's blind type I don't
I've never said I think the game's gonna
be a 10 out of 10. never said that I
still have questions about combat I
still have questions about story
um but what I am like completely sold on
number one is exploration
uh number two is like authenticity I I
felt like those were two of the biggest
things like just that being able to go
and explore Hogwarts
if this game was literally a walking
simulator I've seen several people say
this and I agree
is it what I want like is it my ideal
for the game no but if it was literally
just like you go through Hogwarts and
you find Collectibles and you talk to
people and you hang out in the common
rooms and there's like nothing you can
connect
my expectations to be met I'd be happy I
would be I would think this is awesome
it would still be fun exactly Clint
exactly
so for me like that's where my
expectations are my hype is obviously
much higher than that
the part that really got me thinking
though in that video oh wait hold on I
need to catch a bunch of comments here
voices of faces are a little off I get
that I will say they looked
in the footage from the the ccxp
the British Comic-Con or British the
Brazilian Comic-Con
it looked ridiculously good like so much
better than what we had seen before
I was I was shocked at how good it
looked
I mean it was it was like night and day
compared to what we had seen so far
93 quarters out of 10 ether says calling
it now
Luna I want a Hogwarts School simulator
would be so happy
uh let's see three Hillary I'm just
worried about how I will feel watching
you play as I wait till April oh gotcha
yeah if you're playing on a PS4 or Xbox
one
[Music]
hold on I want to see what Chris said
it's okay because if the game is a flop
I go to Universal Harry Potter World in
March right
hype is for what the devs have shown us
that's it marvolo says like see like if
your hype is based on realistic stuff if
your expectations are based on realistic
possibilities
then you know I think that's I think
that's fine right
and I also now to be fair like we're not
gonna have time to go through every
single part of Luke's video here but
just to be fair to him like I do think
he was coming from a good place with
this I I don't think he meant I don't
think he meant to and if you watch the
video you'll see this he does talk about
some of the good things talks about some
of the bad things I don't think he meant
to hate on Hogwarts Legacy in any way
he's just like hey here's some things
that concern me here's some things I'm
excited about
and just sort of leave left it at that
you know some of his concerns I agree
are concerned some I'm like uh I don't
know about that
um he talked about like he talked a lot
about WB and some some of their recent
history uh particularly Middle Earth
shadow of War
which had you know tons of micro
transactions that they actually had to
walk back some of them it was it was not
a good situation
and then he points to the thing with the
Stark Arts pack being locked behind this
paywall you know or if or the deluxe
edition
and I think there's been some confusion
he didn't outright say it but I think
some people are taking that as the the
curses themselves which that's not true
as we talked about last week
and there are two more of those that are
not behind the paywall
and so it remains to be seen like how
big of a deal that is
um also you know I'm not a fan of the
exclusivity stuff I'm not I I think
there are a lot of PC folks here there
are a lot of Xbox folks here
I mean and I say that being as someone
who I'm gonna play on PS5 you know
even knowing that though I don't feel
like it's going to
I mean they said on the website no
microtransactions could they go against
that man it would be
it'd be really really difficult to swing
that after that has been on the website
for so long no micro transactions
I definitely think we will get some some
post-launch DLC at some point though
definitely
[Music]
uh Jack said my only problem with
Hogwarts is the magic casting doesn't
feel all that Dynamic a few of the
Spells are just directional movement
pull up push down spells one laser beams
hmm
I don't know about that
I don't know about that I feel like the
combat
it's so unique like honestly the the
recent Witcher update I need to try that
because the way The Witcher update
handles the Spells is I think somewhat
similar to how Hogwarts is going to do
it where you have to like hold the
trigger then you press one of the face
buttons
after playing Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire today though let me tell
you it's gonna be loads better than that
I can guarantee
oh Dirtbag face has a countdown
I know Dirtbag they uh they respond on
Twitter to me quite a bit
yeah the devs 100 you can tell they care
about about the game Luke talks about
that in his video too
remember when we were all upset it was
three months away
man no it's it's like right there now
it's right there
right there
white wolf I watched the video
completely understand his stance
completely because this is me 95 of the
time I don't think he's paid much
attention on his followed about the game
based on comments interesting okay
[Music]
oh Clint what what were you referring to
it's very good retro much better I
missed your uh
I'm so behind on chat I missed what it
was or you might be talking about
Shadow War
Big Lebowski they added the
microtransactions after the fact
yikes
they would melt down they would they
would go into meltdown mode yeah that
would be
that would be pretty shady and
unfortunate if they did that
uh Tim same here really dislike platform
exclusivity deals I know why it's done
still feels quote dirty to some degree
[Music]
oh yeah Krista the combat for sure looks
better
for sure looks better
and then uh one of his other big
issues is the collectors of it not
really issue but just pointing out how
you know the collector's edition is
mostly controlled by WB anybody who's
following my channel knows that I have
been
pretty outspoken that it's not a good
value even as someone who thinks the
wand looks cool which some people don't
like the wand I actually think the wand
looks really cool but the price is too
high I've said that a number of times
for what you're getting
he talks about that
talks about the history of the
developers which we've we've covered
that on this channel we've covered that
at length so
I don't know if we should really rehash
that one too much
apparently there were some big YouTubers
who were still confusing this Avalanche
for the Avalanche devs who did just
cause which
I'm like oh man where are you guys we
were talking about this a year and a
half
ago
clarifying that for everybody
Timothy ninja I don't expect Hogwarts
likes you to be the best game ever made
or anything but I think it has enough
going for it there will at least be some
parts of the game I'll enjoy even it's
not perfect that's me Timothy like I
know I I know I'm gonna love this game
even with all its flaws
and maybe it's partially because
you can already I mean you can already
tell from what they've shown how much
care how much time how much attention to
detail has been put in compared to the
old games which were the the old school
Harry Potter games were under a constant
like time crunch with just about every
one of those to get them out to turn
them around for the movies
and those like especially the first
three we had some very Charming some
very good moments but they had their
flaws right and we still look back on
especially those first three we look
back on pretty fondly most everybody I
see commenting on my Let's Plays for
them commenting on live streams
everybody looks back on those games
fondly
loving all their flaws at the same time
so I think the same thing could very
well happen with Hogwarts Legacy even if
it's not you know this this perfect 10
out of 10 game
Carmine yes a little bit a little bit
used to stream there a lot started
hoping to get back into it more gaming
stream so we did one this morning and
probably going to be doing another live
stream tomorrow morning as well guys
over on Twitch if you're interested
picking up our Goblet of Fire Let's Play
We started this morning around 9 30
Eastern time so it might be a little bit
later than that might be around 10 or 10
or so Eastern tomorrow but still like
you know in the early early part of the
day
oh man I knew you guys were gonna be
flowing with the comments tonight I'm so
far behind here
um what Edition will I be purchasing for
definitely
I have a collector's pre-order just
because I feel like
for you guys the viewers I need to unbox
one for the channel and talk about the
quality of the materials
as I mentioned I think it's overpriced
complete transparency I do have one
pre-ordered a collector's edition
however I will say if I didn't have this
YouTube channel I would I would just go
with the deluxe I would just go with the
deluxe
so there you go take that take that as
you will I mean eventually though I
think the one will look pretty cool
right back here I do as people make fun
of me for spending 300 on it though most
likely
[Music]
don't think WB would get away with
adding microtransactions after release I
don't think so either and I think
Avalanche would strongly resist that I
don't know how much you know who knows
what that Dynamic is like you know
portkey is another party at work here
when you're dealing with a property like
Harry Potter and IP this big I know it's
not Harry Potter but it's it's a
Wizarding World IP
there are so many so so many involved
[Music]
yeah SP good question I mean we're gonna
keep doing content we're gonna keep
doing weekly live streams so obviously
SP asked this is back in the chat a
little bit but have you thought about
how your content will shift after it's
released and what you'd like to focus on
next so probably going to be doing more
gaming live streams and then I also have
more
what do you call it like Hannah
Evergreen videos like story based videos
that are about stories of video games
and characters in video games couple of
those in the works
and then we'll keep covering gaming news
too you know
I feel like we've kind of found a nice
little niche here with maybe we shift to
covering more action RPGs I really want
to play the new Star Wars game
plan on doing some coverage for that
although I don't know how much because
that comes out so soon after Hogwarts
Legacy but that gives you an idea we're
still going to do a weekly Tuesday live
stream it'll just shift more into
General news General gaming news not
General news heck no I don't want to
talk do not want to talk about world
news geez I talk about the gaming news
to escape from all that
here we go with Ravenclaw again
so loud
but yeah yeah good question uh SP good
question
[Music]
only played chamber uh that is another
good point Dr Sherbert yes that it is
timed the exclusivity is timed
for one year
[Music]
chamber Secrets was Elite right
seen lots of pretty games don't really
care as much as when it was first showed
off is that about uh Hogwarts or
something else
foreign
I need to play that one Casey I started
playing it on a live stream but it there
were so many little quirks to get it
running that it was totally botching
messing up our stream
Professor Baxter collector's edition
disappointment for sure
yeah I mean I've I've talked about it
enough I don't want to revisit it I
don't want to revisit it
going from Cars 3 to Hogwarts Legacy yes
like that's a big jump that's a big jump
I will say as Troy Levitt has pointed
out like on the flip side
first of all those games weren't bad
I went back like after watching Luke's
video I went back I was like I want to
look at what some of these games have
have reviewed and kids games among
mainstream video game folks they rarely
ever are gonna review well but these
were like you know 70 70 range or so on
a lot of these games
I I read a lot of Luke's comments as
well and some people in the comments
were talking about how these games were
actually really good like for kids games
you know you have to design those games
a certain way you have to design those
worlds a certain way some people were
saying they were a little repetitive
um but what they were and what Troy
Levitt has talked about former employee
at Avalanche is how and of course you
know he has his own bias view of working
there for as long as he did
but that they're really good at getting
into an IP understanding what people
love about it
and then bringing it to life in the game
and being true to that so Cars 3 and toy
I actually heard really good things
about Toy Story 3. never played that one
but heard really good things about that
one
and so yeah this is a big jump for them
absolutely it's a huge jump for them
no doubt about it
but I think they're ready for it I do
you're a wizard Harry I think they're
ready for it
and I think like just hearing the people
talk you can hear how passionate they
are and they wouldn't they would not
have delayed the game like this as many
times as they have if they weren't um
dude I am so sorry guys I missed
I've missed so much
uh Valerian Sith Lord renewing their
membership
welcome Sith Lord
you are now officially a member of House
wrecking tour thank you for being here
my friend dream and plays games with the
Super Chat as well been following the
game since the beginning kind of ashamed
to say I just watched all the movies for
the first time no way
realized I knew nothing about Laura even
after the first showcase that is now see
dreaming that is such an interesting
perspective
that is such an interesting perspective
somebody who's like this game looks kind
of cool getting into the lore into the
original series through that I
definitely feel like you're in the
minority but still I think it's a very
interesting perspective thank you so
much for the Super Chat as well and then
we had house with a super chat it's
about the unrestricted access to the
world uh that is what's going to make
this game that's always been the fantasy
for most of us house in the house indeed
thank you for being here house good to
see you
Antoine one through three five through
six eight right
Antoine well and the Lego games the Lego
games were solid
Lego games were solid
psycho I'm excited for Hogwarts so I can
see but can't stop thinking about a
potential Narnia open world what is that
a thing are they actually making one
what's up Lauren welcome or Laura I'm
sorry
Dirtbag I'd be a little disappointed but
I'd never regret the hype
okay
thank you for oh wait and then psycho
psycho with a super chat too oh my
goodness I need to just scroll all the
way to the top psycho my friend good to
see you here thank you so much for the
Super Chat ready to log out all my
social media due to being deployed don't
get back till end of March oh my
goodness dude
so you're just gonna be like totally Off
the Grid psycho
no communication or anything
don't get back to the end of March
wow
thank you again for your service psycho
[Music]
are you gonna be the third guest host
Callum asks
no
no I'm not
I can't find the original leak video I
think it's still out there somewhere
Shadow guided
uh Dirtbag face hey somebody was just
talking about you dirt bag
I feel so
I feel so bad saying like
I mean it is your name but I feel like
I'm belittling you dirt bag
dirt back face it just feels so wrong
uh BN do we get to pick our house or do
they choose it uh you can actually if
you go to Wizarding World
you can take the quiz there link it to
the game to your WB account and it will
bring it over or you can do it in game
so I don't think it's just gonna
outright shoes for you though
we don't know how it's going to be
handled yet in game I mean the website
has said for a while you'll choose your
house the startup Hogwarts Legacy I
don't know if it's just going to be a
simple like hey you pick or if you'll
have a little quiz in game but yeah
they're not just gonna randomly assign
it
almost 200 likes oh my goodness and we
already forgot I think we're gonna have
to start pushing the uh
so whenever we hit 100 likes in a live
stream guys we do a random quote from
the Harry Potter series a little bit of
Harry Potter quote trivia and then if we
hit 200 we do a random Harry Potter
impression
I think we're gonna have to start
pushing that to the end because I just I
mean if you're new here
this is how our streams go dude we get
it's just a chat man you guys are such
and I mean that in the best way possible
you guys ask lots of good questions you
guys make lots of good comments that are
worth discussing and then I bring them
up on stream and I go on like a 15
minute tangent and then I've just I'm 15
minutes behind in chat and then I have
to start scrolling back through and then
it's just this never-ending cycle you
know
this never-ending cycle
more excited to explore than the battle
and such Christy says
yeah I can't wait to just get in there
and explore
can't wait to get in there and explore
this world
love that we're discussing hype also
hyped and concerned for black myth
Wukong see like
now Mary you bring up another
another angle to this
being hyped about something
while also having legitimate concerns
I've made videos on legitimate concerns
and I'm still freaking hyped for the
game you know
yo expecto go with a super chat what is
up my friend
James
visiting Avalanche software people will
be surprised by the story yo James
dropping some teases here live
James dropping some teases here in the
Stream to me Story music and Hogwarts
are the most important parts and they've
nailed it there you go guys a man one of
the few people
who has received an up close
behind-the-scenes look at the game
you guys don't know our boy James expect
to go here was the host one of the the
co-host
for the first
gameplay showcase
and yeah if you haven't watched his
behind the scenes video you get another
that's on his YouTube channel that gives
you another look at the people behind
the scenes man and you can so you could
so tell
how excited and passionate they are
about it for sure and and to be again to
be fair to Luke he brings that up in his
video as well
no what's up noob
I haven't seen you chatting as much
tonight noob
Noob said speed
now that is a great segue wait where
people like were people seriously
talking politics what the heck
what the heck no no no no no we stay far
away for politics here on this channel
folks
stay far away from politics in my real
life let me tell you uh but Noob said
speaking of politics do you think we can
go to the ministry Magic
gut reaction no
but I would love it if we did dude I
would love it if we did
would be awesome
don't really feel a hype for most games
because the idea of updating after
release has really changed how games are
made I feel less passionate
see that's another and another valid
completely valid perspective right like
I we hate to say it right we don't even
want to consider it but Hogwarts Legacy
could launch an estate
where there are bugs you hope not
but there will be a day one patch that
is going to try to fix a lot of things
and there may be more pattern there
there will be more patches for sure
right
Tom how's it going Tom
Chris haven't taken the quiz in 10 plus
years wanted to retake before the game
comes out apparently turning into James
Hufflepuff with a thestral Patronus
Rowan wand with unicorn core uh oh
another Hufflepuff joining the ranks
you're a wizard Harry
draco's like wait do you know the story
already James do you know the story
Ashley with a super chat as well Ashley
thank you so much Hogwarts Legacy is
giving us a way to make the world our
own and shape it along with our own
experiences for me that is what I'm
looking forward to nice Ashley thank you
thank you for the Super Chat and thank
you for sharing your perspective on this
man I knew you guys would have some good
takes I knew you all have some good
comments
so to just to kind of wrap up
the discussion of uh Luke's video
um which I think we've done a good job
of show like he he talks about some pros
he talks about some cons my biggest
point of discussion that I wanted to
talk about was this just this idea of a
hype and like is it
a bad thing I think sometimes it can be
I don't think it always is
um and he he says like he outright says
on his channel he he wants to create a
culture of not buying into hype that is
unwarranted
um and he also talks about how YouTubers
have a responsibility to viewers to try
and be level-headed recognizing that you
know what we say could have a huge
impact on buying decisions of people
I see that and I get that at the same
time
I also
I also trust like you I trust you guys
to see what I'm showing to see what I'm
talking about and to be able to make
your own choice and whether or not you
should be excited or hyped for a game
because you know what you like in a game
right I mean to some people Elder ring
is a 10 to me Elder ring is an absolute
tin yet anytime I talk about Elder ring
I see comments where people talk about
it's just not for me that game's not for
me not for me not for me I get it like I
totally get it both perspectives are
valid
but yeah so so
and then he mentions a comment at the
end he said that
if you follow like like his channel is
one that doesn't
hype people up for easy clicks that
tries to be level-headed and honest with
you and so that's really that's another
thing I really want to make sure I
discuss because I don't think I've
ever been and I would never be dishonest
with you guys would never be dishonest
with you guys anything that I make a
video about I mean you guys know like I
I try to keep it pretty level-headed I
try and if I have concerns we talked
about the collector's edition we talked
about avalanches previous games we've
talked about all these things before
and I try to keep a level head yet at
the same time if I'm excited about
something I'm also gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna share that with you guys and so I
don't think he was I don't think it was
a shot at our Channel I think it was I
think it was maybe talking about some
larger YouTubers who haven't covered
Hogwarts like we do and then make videos
hyping it up to get clicks I I don't
know I don't know maybe he was talking
about us I don't know
um but as a channel who we have I mean
I wouldn't say I don't know how much a
vast majority of our channel so far has
been devoted to to Hogwarts Legacy into
covering this game
um and really always trying to cover it
with a fair eye but also you guys know
like you know my perspective you know
how big of a fan I am of The Wizarding
World
you know
so I feel like you guys is the audience
you could take that into account and
so would I be do I see comments you know
not people in the live streams because
you guys in the live streams I mean you
all get me more than anyone else like
you all know how I think about games and
in the videos the videos my videos are
always you know they're very
they're not as in-depth as as like
Luke's videos they don't go that long at
least on most of them
so you get just you know a snapshot and
so I do get a lot of comments on those
videos like people talking about you
know I can't believe people are buying
into the hype I can't believe you're
like me specifically you're hyping it up
like this
um I see those comments but I I know
that the real ones you guys hear the
ones watching the live stream you guys
know where I come from and what I'm what
I'm about and why I'm so excited about
the game so
that's me man that's me
we are past 200 likes Dr Sherman says
let's go
it's not above critique we can be hype
but also be rational there you go Chris
and like if the game comes out and has
problems
I I will we will talk about it
we will talk about it I hope it runs
well I hope the frame rate runs well I
do
I hope it runs at a nice solid glorious
60 FPS on the PS5 performance mode maybe
even above 60 maybe maybe
he gets you get that sometimes as well
gotta War Ragnarok man runs very nicely
but yeah I mean if everything's a fetch
Quest then we'll talk about it we'll
talk about it then
but I would just know I would never be
i i i i actively try and avoid
[Music]
what's the word like
I'm trying to think of how he worded it
in his video like blindly hyping you
know you got to be careful of that
but telling you guys like hey they
showed this thing and it actually looks
really cool and I'm excited about it
and leaving it at that not saying you
should be too
but even if I did say hey I think this
looks cool if you're a Potter fan you
should be excited about this you know
uh let's see let's see let's see
Draco did not like Elder ring at all for
the first few hours but I say the game
is a 9 out of ten story was hard yeah
the story is
story is for sure hard to follow Sky
Laura I would never play Elder ring
personally Ryan oh eldering literally
not on my radar oh see there you go
there you go
that's right Dr sherbet yeah before the
end of the Stream
current rig can't run Elder ring no
Rodrigo let's be honest here before the
state of play not even the most
optimistic height person would have
guessed that we would have if a variant
for our own fantastic Beast
agreed Rodrigo agreed
Lauren retro you're just as high
possessed and there's nothing wrong with
that yeah see that's the other thing I
want people to know like if you are
somebody
that sees that video and you're like oh
well he's telling me I shouldn't get
excited for this game
I don't think he should feel like that I
don't
another Super check coming in from uh
Phoenix there two minutes ago gosh I am
so sorry and then Luna comics
member of House record tour
thank you Luna thank you Luna for being
a member of House Records who are here
and then we had the Super Chat mini
games are important they create
important easy to remember experiences
and create a great break from repetitive
gameplay yeah that's the one thing we
don't know
ah
I wouldn't say it's been mostly negative
but it's like no Wizard's Chest no
gobstones no Quidditch
but we know there's the broom races and
then they show off this whole vivarium
thing
which to me
I don't think that's gonna be the only
thing I don't I think there's gonna be
even more stuff to do and you know they
got to keep some stuff under wraps you
know
uh I think I read Chris's comment if I
didn't it's not about critique we could
be hype but be rational yeah I agree
with that
uh Tom definitely not with this game if
anything I've been more impressed the
gameplay showcases keeps the hype going
it shows the effort and care they put
into making this amazing game
Casey not being allowed by a cell phone
to donate no
I don't know maybe one of the mods can
help you out Casey I don't know if
you're trying to just outright donate
like um
like a oh geez like through a
donation or if you're trying to do the
Super Chat
[Music]
oh and then sorry Case Casey don't feel
good good night ever oh sorry to hear
you're not feeling well Casey have a
good one
so you're gonna be more or less hyped
after this stream oh me Ryan like my I
am I am totally satisfied with my hype
level
I am totally satisfied just when you
when you see a big YouTuber say that
[Music]
like the that YouTubers have a certain
responsibility not to misguide people or
mislead people like I agree with that
you know
but I also don't think I should tell you
guys what to believe if I share
something and say hey
they showed this thing and it looks
really cool and I'm excited about it and
you get it excited about it too then I'm
okay with that I can live with that you
know
now the question our poll question guys
let's see what the result is at now
the poll question oh my goodness almost
600 votes are you kidding me
if Hogwarts Legacy doesn't live up to
expectations will you regret hyping it
up 22 okay so this one has increased a
little bit up to 22 saying yes now 78
say no it's about the journey
all right I'm gonna answer that question
now myself I'm gonna go ahead and end
the poll as well
and I'm gonna answer it now so
I will not regret it
I will not regret it because I don't
think there's anything where I have
outright
I don't think I've misrepresented
anything that Avalanche has shown this
channel we report on the game we report
on things that they show
and then I react to them I tell you guys
if I'm excited about them I tell you
guys if I'm concerned about them
I tell you guys predictions what I think
may happen what may not happen
um but I will not regret it man because
this alone like all of this
the conversations would I be
disappointed
absolutely
absolutely but I would be disappointed
if I never started this YouTube channel
if I never made a video if I never made
a single video about Hogwarts Legacy
still be disappointed if the game came
out and it wasn't good I would
so the hype in a lot of ways like this
this lead up this excitement and full
transparency full disclosure you guys
know I've talked about I mean part of
this is influenced by my love for the
books my love for this world my love for
for the fandom and for being in that
world in between each book The Hype the
anticipation
now with that maybe you could argue you
had a little bit more to go by because
you knew the author you knew you are you
knew what she was capable of writing and
kind of had an idea of where the story
was going whereas this is a little bit
more of an unknown
but guess what even if Hogwarts Legacy
totally bombs like I'm saying let's just
say it launches and it's just like
worse than cyberpunk worst case scenario
like it's unplayable at launch
would I be very disappointed yes but you
know what
if they announce the Hogwarts Legacy too
or if another Dev said hey we're making
this Harry Potter game we're making an
RPG we're making an open world we're
making an MMO whatever
I'd be hyped again I'd be hyped again
because I know I can see a vision in my
head of how good a game in this world
could be
in this game has the potential
the potential to do that it has the
potential that is where a lot of my hype
comes from and then my expectations
come from what they've shown us which
the majority of it I've been very
pleased by some concerns absolutely
majority have been very pleased by able
Knight Road zero two with a super chat
as well top five thing you want to do
once you can go anywhere and do anything
ooh I love this question able Knight and
thanks so much for the Super Chat as
well
I've seen I think there was a Reddit
post asking or somebody was making maybe
making a comment saying the first thing
they're gonna do is like go and check
for the
Chamber of Secrets see if you can find
the Chamber of Secrets
I don't think I'll do that but
I think the first thing I'll do is just
want to take like a stroll through the
castle
just like
I don't know if everything well we know
some doors are going to be locked not
everything's going to be open even in
the castle right away
but just try and get an idea of how of
how big and massive the castle is like
how much there is to explore and do in
that
all big RPG releases with a certain
amount of bugs right the bigger the game
the bigger the chance as long as they're
not game breaking I don't care right and
as long as they're committed to like oh
yep we're gonna fix that
oh no Shadow guided sorry to hear that
cyberpunk eventually got good only a
year later
maybe I should play it now
maybe I should play it
oh I like that's a good question too
Ryan how broken would the game actually
have to be for us to flip our response
I mean pretty broken pretty broken
pretty broken which I think they're
committed to not having that happen
I think they delay it again if they well
actually it's already went gold so
but I think that I mean we've seen
wasn't there one game that like went
gold and then they still delayed it like
another week or something didn't that
happen or am I crazy
my hype for most games is they tweet
something or Show gameplay and I'm super
excited for like two days to forget
about it until I see it again
uh sync I'm still happy to be able to
explore Hogwarts
foreign
gonna be so fun
oh yeah Jax we're gonna have so much
Hogwarts Legacy content
walkthroughs Secrets lore discussions
all that all that
uh Niraj Aidan Raj how's it going we
gotta have faith in the team because
they've been honest with us from the
start
when they can be honest they've been
honest right
there are some things that marketing and
PR just aren't going to
you know I mean to your point though
they have I mean they've even showed
bugs like oh my gosh look at this crazy
bug we're working on fixing this right
now
oh I think we're the ones who showed
ramrock the ancient Magic
JP just exploring Hogwarts and riding
brooms is enough for me
either not a chance and hogsmeade it
will bomb
uh skylara then she killed beloved
characters in those books a game may be
safer
thank you nagura thank you
oh the game definitely isn't gonna bomb
in terms of sales that's not what I'm
talking about
for those of you saying 100 not gonna
bomb I'm not talking about sales I think
it could release pretty poorly and still
sell well
um
but I'm just saying like if it's you
know if there were major major gameplay
issues
played cyberpunk day one on PS5 very
little problems and thoroughly enjoyed
it I heard that from I wouldn't say a
lot of people Draven but I did hear that
from some people
I had a buddy at work who played gosh I
think he played it on his
did it release on 360
no it didn't release on 360. on his Xbox
One
and
he he still he said he had a great time
with it and the bugs were just more
like humorous than anything so
I don't know I still haven't played it
myself
yeah I agree moonly
that's that's the one thing that's been
ever since the devs were able to get in
front of us and start talking
I mean really since the first blog that
um Adrian Rob I think was the
person's name and then we've seen posts
from Alan and we've seen them talking in
the interviews and then the Showcase is
really I think that's really when we
started to get a sense of
oh these these people really care like
they really care about this world they
really care about doing it justice this
is a game they've been wanting to play
for years themselves
most game devs don't release much more
than a trailer or two given that
Avalanche has showed a lot more content
there's more evidence to back to higher
expectations
yeah see I don't feel like I don't feel
like any of my
expectations are are blind or based on
things that
aren't accurate now one thing we do have
to consider is that in these demos I
mean they're showing what's what's known
as a vertical slice of a game
so that section may look great then you
may get somewhere else and it's terrible
they've showed us a lot though right
they showed us a lot
Odin killer 9 with a super chat retro if
you can have a new game based off any
other wizard school what would you pick
oh
I mean being US based
it's pretty hard not to say over morning
but
oh man
like wagadu would have some really
interesting story possibilities for sure
[Music]
house Thunderbird that was my house too
nerdy giant with the Super Chat as well
nerdy giant thank you so much for your
support people always say lower
expectations however being excited
doesn't hurt anyone hate when others
tell others how to feel
see nerdy giant like that's I mean
people have been saying it I love the
Harry Potter game subreddit
love love a lot of the people there but
that is something that has been a
concept on there people saying
keep your expectations in check keep
your expectations in check manage your
expectations
and I've always been like okay if you if
that makes you feel better fine
but like the journey for me as we said
in our poll question the journey and the
build up and the lead up
I love that stuff man
I love that stuff and I agree with you
dude like telling people don't be hyped
for it
it kind of rubs me the wrong way a
little bit as well when people are like
don't be hyped which video we were
talking about earlier didn't didn't say
that it was just raising some concerns
like hey
before you get so hyped make sure you
know this too
is my is my take on it but yeah nerdy
giant I'm right there with you
and that's why in all my videos I feel
like I'm just
my stance is like hey I think this
stuff's cool if you guys agree
awesome thank you for being here and
hanging out and if you don't agree then
hey let's talk about it right
now you only you know your own
personality and like how you like if
you're just gonna be absolutely
devastated right if the game doesn't
live up to your hype then maybe it is a
good lesson and healthy for you to be
like oh man maybe I don't want to do
that again
but I'll tell you guys like I've been
hyped for a lot of things like I'm just
I'm a huge like I love getting into
fandoms and just reading message boards
and theories and discussion like Harry
Potter started all of that for me then I
have watched countless shows and movies
and games over the years where I've done
the same thing
books book series I mean some of them
have disappointed me
some of them have met expectations some
of them have blown away expectations and
I don't regret any of the hype don't
regret any of it lost dude lost is a
really good example
[Music]
lost I absolutely love that show listen
to so many podcasts I used to blog about
the show Lost talk to so many people
about it
and I still don't feel like the last
season was as bad as everyone else does
but I don't do I don't regret any of
that man like the conversations and the
discussion and the and and the
excitement leading up to it all I don't
regret any of it
so even for the things that
haven't worked out or lived up to what I
hoped
I still maybe it's just a personality
thing you know maybe it's just a
personality difference like
I'm able to bounce back like it's not
gonna hurt my feelings so much to where
I'm just gonna never get over it again
Christy with a super chat as well yo
thank you Christy
Christy member of housewrecking tour
also a moderator here on the stream uh
Christy says fast play to get the story
or slow for exploring
it's gonna be really hard for me not to
explore Christy I think it's gonna be
really hard
I uh I'm currently playing through God
of War Ragnarok though and I am noticing
that I feel more drawn to the story so I
replayed God of War 2018 before Ragnarok
and came away with such a different
impression of that game because I did
everything I got the Platinum defeated
all the Valkyries
and because I knew the story I just went
at my own pace dare I say I actually
enjoyed it more than my first
playthrough I actually enjoyed it more
than my first playthrough
but yet even knowing that now when I'm
playing Ragnarok I'm trying to like
explore a little more but then I'm like
oh I want to know what happens I want to
know what happens
so I say that I will want to explore in
Hogwarts Legacy but I will probably I
mean if the story really draws me in you
know I might just I might get locked in
on it but surely they're going to have a
mode or set you before the last mission
or something where you can do that free
roam at the end I really hope so nerdy
giant with another Super Chat as well uh
nerdy giant I don't need this game to be
10 out of 10 or even game of the year
I'm getting what I want and that's the
ability to live my life in the Wizarding
World
preach nerdy Giant
that's I agree I agree with you I don't
need it to be 10 out of 10. I don't
uh Big Mac not over hyped but can't wait
personal pick would be the Japanese
school lore behind their robes is pretty
cool I mean they would all be
interesting I feel like
ether don't want to end up at a spider
cocoon
right Hannah how's it going Hannah
welcome and then Maple Street pictures
with another Super Chat thank you so
much Mabel Street although no playable
Wizarding games quidditch chess
gobstones exploding snaps makes the game
feel a little incomplete I think for
myself the game has far exceeded my
expectations so far
I agree
I agree I think I think it has already
exceeded
what the expectations I have for it in
terms of what we've seen
so now like for me as long as it runs
well dude I'm good as long as it runs
well
I don't even need like this incredible
story I know a lot of you are real real
big on story I'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell somebody
call me on that in a video when I said I
was like gameplay above story always
like wait a second aren't you the dad
who loves games and the stories they
tell
touche my friend touche uh but still I
will die on that hill of gameplay above
story always and forever
um if it's if if story you know
obviously you want a good story my
favorite game of all time are games that
are that they merge story and gameplay
in a very
um unique way
I'm all about that but if I had to pick
one
I want the gameplay dude I want the
better gameplay if I just want a good
story I'll go read the books again but
hopefully it's good as well
but yeah thank you for the Super Chat
Maple Street thank you for hanging out
okay this is a good comment from latch
for me here I think there are lots of
people who build up hype on a foundation
of what ifs when hype is built on
features or depths of features that
haven't been announced it can lead to
big disappointment I do agree with that
I do agree with that like for a long
time and I I still even now will get
comments of people thinking this is an
MMO and expecting MMO like gameplay
features now that type of thing again
I'm not going to tell you
whether to get hyped or not
but like that I could see how that could
lead to disappointment right if you're
getting hyped for things that or you're
counting on something being in the game
and then you're you're like way off yeah
I could see that
uh like whatever with expectations
oh no
oh no
the comments moved
the comments jumped too far ahead
and I missed so much of them are we yes
arctics that's the perfect example I was
thinking about that earlier today when I
Was preparing for this video and it
totally slipped my mind I'm glad you
brought it up
how's it going Hayden welcome
dare I bring up Game of Thrones yes yes
the first what was it five seasons
some of the best TV so good incredible
and obviously the hype was through the
roof for the remaining seasons
they did not live up to the hype
was it disappointing absolutely do I
regret
the excitement and all the the podcasts
I listened to and the message boards and
the forums that I read no don't regret
any of it
and don't regret it at all you wish they
could go back and redo those last couple
Seasons yeah I do
I do indeed but yeah thank you for
bringing that one up that is that's
that's exactly what I'm talking about
there uh go ninja been hyped for the
last few Assassins Creed games Valhalla
was the only let down with both
storyline and fighting
yeah trying to think of the most recent
game that I've been hyped for
it didn't live up to expectations
oh
gosh it's been a while man mainly
because I'm so selective with the games
I play these days
man as you get older guys and you uh
basically have two jobs and a family
kids wife
the gameplay like I really have to be
selective with the games I play so
man it's been a long time it really it's
been a really long time since I like was
was all in all game bought it and was
like oh my gosh no it almost happened
with returnal
the PS5 game which is coming to PC
but I stuck with it and ended up loving
that game
never finished the first God of War
Tater says uh you mean like the 2018 one
or do you mean the like the the original
original
uh SP I want to play the demo for spoken
it looks kind of cool but then I also I
heard some people saying the demo was
kind of eh
eh not that good
just realize if there are Kelpie robes
and that means there are Kelpies could
be
could be
oh wait I missed the Super Chat from
Phoenix again the player C uses both
left
hold up
hold up am I reading this wrong or is
there a language a language barrier
thing here the player C uses both left
or right hand
I'm not following you Phoenix if you try
to just post it in the regular chat
a clarification I'll try to catch it
there but thank you so much for the
Super Chat
uh Tater with a super chat the Quarry
was my biggest letdown last year
so how did you feel afterwards tater
like do you regret
getting excited for it
because I just like I've never had that
mentality when it comes to video games
in my life I never have
now I have with other things in my life
like sports for example oh man
I'm a Tennessee Titans fan and so I have
gotten very accustomed to
with that oh now this is super
interesting with that I do I always set
my expectations super low
I'm just like I don't expect us to do
well and then if they do I'm like yes
because I eat man I used to like I used
to be really bad about letting letting
Sports get to me so much where it would
just like ruin my day it just ruined my
day sometimes a couple of days I would
just be so annoyed and miserable if my
favorite team lost gotten a lot better
about that with age but maybe it's
because I'm setting my expectations
lower but with games I've never had that
problem I feel like because there are so
many games
so many movies so many TV shows like if
one disappoints me yeah that's
unfortunate but move on to the next one
you know
on to the next one Krista I explore so
much in games like these takes me
forever to complete the story I love it
uh ether game definitely doesn't feel
incomplete there's no way it would ever
have everything true yeah
game looks sick I don't care what anyone
said I mean I agree like I think based
off what we've seen I like what we've
seen
[Music]
Ragnarok very story focused doesn't
pushed exploration
I yeah I would agree with that it is
very much more
linear but it kind of is like it's open
world
you reach a point where you can go
anywhere but it's still very linear in
nature
it's I mean I love it I'm a fan of both
both of them
scalar actually didn't want Wizarding
World games
too much takes away enjoyment oh I see
what you mean like gobstones and all
that
Tom says this is part of the process for
all new games rare to have a game being
released where the developers show us a
lot without actually showing us
everything that's the beauty Pockets
like yeah
they have shown quite a bit but
according to channel wood only the tip
of the iceberg
Williams says not gonna lie I'm override
at least you admit it William like
you're in a comfortable spot you admit
you're a little bit overhyped
my PS5 will be here tomorrow and it just
shipped tonight let's go ether dude
that's crazy fast shipping nice
he said it roll credits wait what did I
say Nico what did I say
remember requirement
um seems like it will be enough of a
mini game in and of itself I agree seems
like it's going to be so much there
oh my gosh I'm so far behind in chat
all right we're gonna get caught up
quickly here
gonna get caught up quickly let me
scroll through here I'm looking I'm
specifically looking for Phoenix's
comment because I
I misunderstood their question here
uh see a question about a dating system
for a time I thought they might
similar to something like persona but
for now I don't think so I think it's
going to be more just like General like
friendships instead but a PS5 just for
this game
[Music]
ebony uh it is not coming in the US
version
foreign
ebony asked about the map so there was a
physical map that was shown with the
I think it was the
the Brazilian at that Brazilian Comic
Con we talked about but or division who
was here earlier and who covered that
event very closely found out at some
point apparently it is only exclusive to
that territory
most unfortunately I was disappointed by
that too
please
bought a PS5 just for this game
[Music]
I know I hope I hope the PS5 is is
stable
hopefully it's stable
especially the performance mode
peace uh Big Mac think of basic Hogwarts
not full detail map
Kingdom Hearts 3 story was bad gameplay
10 out of 10.
Nico he couldn't get in Horizon really I
didn't love Horizon I'll give you that I
liked it a lot but I didn't love it
and nerdy giant with another yet another
Super Chat nerdy giant with the crazy
love and support tonight thank you nerdy
giant hoping DLC after launch with
adding wizard chess quidditch quidditch
could be the multiplayer aspect imagine
walking into the glitchfield and
starting a match with others I mean we
talked about it on the live stream with
a bunch of Hogwarts Legacy content
creators it'd be
some type of multiplayer component at
some point would be awesome but then
there's another part of me that's like
if they nail the story thing
wouldn't I rather see a story DLC and
then maybe WBC like oh my gosh The
Wizarding World
is ripe for another game
these these folks who really are into
this are talking about hey they'd love
to have something to play with each
other which
Harry Potter
um magic awakened come on where you at
but yeah so I I don't know I go back and
forth on if I would want it to be an
expansion Hogwarts Legacy or if I'd want
it to be its own thing Tater with a
super chat as well bought my PS5 in
September for this game got a headset
for Christmas let's go congrats tater
can't wait I bet
[Music]
difficulty Jordan I'll probably just do
the normal to start
[Music]
unless there's a
excuse me unless there's a trophy tied
to difficulty which don't spoil trophies
guys we're we're trying not to spoil the
trophies yes I've already looked and yes
I know whether there is or isn't but
uh Jay yeah some people have uh had to
to re-pre-order
because of cancellations when they
change the date oh my gosh there goes
Ravenclaw again
so loud
Draco most typed I've ever been was Star
Wars Galaxy still have the beta DVDs in
a frame shadow box
yeah TJ I had heard about that
[Music]
yeah make sure you guys if you pre-order
digitally
or honestly or even if you pre-ordered
physical check your pre-orders
especially if it was on like uh lashin
console because of the date a lot of
people changed up some things there
[Applause]
Valyrian as a Cowboys fan I always
expect disappointment uh we had a Colts
fan here as well Michael oh no Michael's
a Jags fan
oh no
and he's a channel member too well sorry
I have to revoke that Michael
I'm kidding Michael
good luck you guys are on quite the
streak and we're on the wrong kind of
streak right now
ridiculous how many injuries they have
ridiculous how many injuries
Dr sherbet with a super chat don't
forget to stay hydrated
just a regular old glass of water
tonight boring tonight guys
[Music]
oh man we got more Super chats
Bobby Bobby thank you for the Super Chat
personally I would love online do you
think it would be good with real people
not just NPCs do you think it would
potentially ruin the game
oh like if they did a if they did some
type of co-op mode I definitely would
want it to be real people
for the longest time I thought they were
gonna go the ghost of tsushima route
I really did I thought they were gonna
put out something post-launched some
sort of like raid-like Mission based
Co-op activity where you go in with I
don't know four or five wizards Wizards
and witches together
and you tackle these like larger
challenges
raid-like activities together
but as it stands right like right now I
think they're gonna be like I think
there's gonna be some
like with the companions that we have in
the game
or just fellow students I guess they're
calling them now
uh I feel like they're gonna be
like I think they're gonna be helping us
out I mean we see that in some of the
clips already like with fig and such
are you gonna pay attention to reviews
at all nerdy giant thank you again for
the Super Chat nerdy giant uh I mean
I'll definitely look at the reviews but
it like
I said it when we did our live stream
with the other Hogwarts because the
creators the first one we did months ago
I mean this game could literally launch
to one out of ten reviews and I'm gonna
play it like
I'm gonna play it
and I'll make my own judgment about it
so but yeah I mean I'll definitely look
at them I'll see what other people are
saying
see what the reception's been
and then another Super Chat
from generation
keep it we'll keep it family friendly
here notice the wand in the gameplay
showcase 2 was different in the dark
arts Arena than the rumor requirement
possibly small wand customization can I
get your opinion well thank you for the
Super Chat my friend
um I think
there is going to be some type of want
customization I do
that has been something I've I've been
asked so many times and had so many
comments about that like even when I
first started covering this game making
videos for this game
I started seeing people ask for that
I think they know people want that I
think it will be very
because they have they want to stay true
to lore though right obviously so
so I think they have to balance that as
well go ninja go Bill's Mafia keep your
oh dude for sure man
for sure guys if you if you believe in
the power of Prayer
or even you know if you don't just send
your general thoughts and Good Vibes to
Buffalo Bills player
I saw I was my wife came I was actually
working on a uh
it's working on something for the stream
and my wife came in here and said this
this guy just got a really bad and so
then I went in and watched like the
whole thing
um American football I know we have a
worldwide audience here but just took a
crazy hit
heart stopped on the field they were
able to restart his heart on the field
but he remains in ICU in a Cincinnati
hospital
game was called off I I have never in my
life see in a game get get start and
then get canceled in in the NFL never
but yeah he needs uh
he needs a lot of prayers right now and
and hopefully a lot of good doctors
which I'm sure he will have top top
Medical Care
I think they did psychopath I think they
did
yeah Lauren it's like this crazy freak
accident where if you get hit
right in the center of your chest
at a specific timing of the heart I've
seen some people describe this it's like
it's like a a precise millisecond
of the heart if you get hit when it's at
that beat first of all you have to get
hit hard enough and then it happens it
has to happen at the precise time
incredibly incredibly rare
incredibly rare if if that's indeed what
it was but yeah it was it was a hard
issue
[Music]
Jonathan Sands just joined call last
minute about fellow student companions
would be great if you can befriend
anyone and those people then join your
pack for certain quests now that talk
about a surprise that would throw people
for a loop Jonathan if that happened
that would throw people for a loop
because we've been we've been so busy
worried about
about whether or not
um certain people are companions or not
have a clarified swimming yet no
no not yet
the more that time goes on the more I
think it's it's gonna be there just
maybe not like full
depth diving with all these all this
stuff going on
foreign
[Music]
guys I am so sorry I'm gonna have to
scroll to the bottom because I'm so I'm
so far behind in the comments
I'm so far behind I just scrolled all
the way to the Bottom now
I am caught up Nico I'm caught up now
now I want to know hold on
did uh did syndrace
ah or a phoenix
ever respond about the player C
left and right hand did they ever
respond about that the clarification on
it
if I missed it I apologize
yo Noob have a good one my friend thank
you for being here
Holly Melancholy trying to keep a level
head
[Music]
yeah that's it elwin that is it yep
that's the medical name for it Jake what
is up Jake
all right I'm gonna go ahead and take
this screen off which I feel like I've
been streaming forever but we're not
we're not even at the two hour mark yet
and we've kind of already finished I
feel like we've we've sort of talked
about the hype topic enough
I'm hyped for the game I'm excited for
the game
and the one thing that we haven't
finished yet from the latest gameplay
showcase is we haven't finished our
breakdown
I'm gonna just like put it right here
and we're gonna mute it for a second
and then we're going to try and talk
about that final
section with the room of requirement
which we've talked we've alluded to that
section A little bit tonight
I missed it she did post about it all
about being the character creator
the player uses both left hand or right
hand so like was it a question
C equals player character and how they
showed the character holding the wands
of different hands
do they
they are shown in trailers building
their wands in different hands
another thing is that they talk about
Wallace magic whoa okay I totally missed
that
I haven't seen any left-handed I'll need
I'll need a time stamp for that I
haven't seen any left-handed wand
usage
[Music]
uh physical map so yeah no physical map
for us
and I don't think for UK either guys
it's apparently just a Brazilian a
Brazilian retailer thing
white wolf comments on another video
I'll do we missed the oh my gosh I'm so
sorry
I'm so sorry
Jay Felix show just so much
blah blah blah blah
showing some love there we go
nailed it
nailed it hey thank you for the Super
Chat Jay just showing some love
appreciate the support my friend and
then Kratos Raptor 85 with a five dollar
Super Chat beat God of War Ragnarok
today for my gaming channel yo let's go
congrats dude I am uh currently playing
through it as well
think I'm about halfway through think of
about halfway probably
can we ride the Hogwarts Express I don't
think so Rain Man
talk about disappointment I am I am
legit sad about that I don't even know
if we're gonna get to see the Hogwarts
Express
common Room videos next what would you
like to see for that nerdy giant we've
done a uh we've done a tier list video
on the common rooms two tier lists
actually
one after kind of the first look and
then one after the more extended look
yeah I was disappointed about the map
too
Mr Mo what's up Mr Moe hey thank you for
stopping by
265 likes
ladies and gentlemen thank you guys for
the love and support if you haven't
already liked the stream make sure to
just if you're enjoying yourself give it
a thumbs up if you're not give it a
thumbs down
I'm serious
give it a thumbs down if you're not
enjoying it if you are having a good
time here give it a thumbs up gonna help
more people find the video
but yeah honestly if you don't enjoy the
stream and you give it a thumbs down
then I hope that helps me too because I
can look back and see oh wow
I must have said something people really
didn't like in that stream
yeah the dislikes can be they can be
helpful sometimes
more often than not they can be helpful
if I if I have a video that's like too
like two clickbaity like if you go too
far in the range of like oh you you
baited me and this isn't what it was
about
dislikes can help with that
Golem sports with a super chat Brazilian
fan here didn't know about the map
though
yeah so
or division who I don't know if ore
division lives in Brazil or what but
they uh and then also there's another
account Hogwarts Legacy
I think it's like h
leg Brazil hold on I don't want to botch
this I want to give you guys the correct
info
as I get behind on chat again but you
know
all right let's see
I think it's
hog leg
Brazil Maybe
oh what is it man
Hogwarts Legacy Brazil Twitter
no
Hogwarts Legacy br
there it is there it is there it is yeah
this account right here
they
posted a lot about the uh
ccxp
[Music]
dude
who gets this
some International influencers are
getting an official
Avalanche please please
oh my gosh
International influencers
come on U.S influencer any any chance
here
oh okay let's see if I can find the
actual one about the map
yeah so the map thing was it it came out
of the whole Comic-Con thing
DJ Steph hey thank you for the Super
Chat as well
let me get to your let me answer this
question and then I'll try to get to
your question there
okay let me just do
ah darn it all right let me see if I
know or division tagged me
[Music]
wait what that's not his Twitter
oh
oh my gosh well I if I can find it I'll
retweet it guys I'll look for it tonight
I don't want to derail the Stream
but follow me uh at retro wrecking tour
I'll try to retweet it if I can find it
but I think I think it's actually been
confirmed as being included with the
physical copy
of I don't know if it's Deluxe or I
don't know if it's standard or both
for for Brazil but I don't know about
anywhere else
right that snow globe that's so nice
that would have been great to include in
the collector's edition Dustin yes
dude if they had included that
the soundtrack
and
a map
plus the wand and everything
oh hold up Nico
okay wait that image
that image Nico somebody's just com
completely flipped the uh
they completely flipped the trailer
that's the shot from
yeah it's just a mirror of the
oh but wait a second though
this is interesting
because the Gryffindor emblem on the
on the robe is correct
but then the signage
is backwards
the signage is backwards
um some people are talking about the
Character Creator was a little
underwhelming it definitely didn't have
some stuff that I expected I think they
went more on the side of
we want to have have options but not
overwhelm people
and as a result I mean yeah it doesn't
have body type doesn't have height
from what we can see you know at least
in this early look that we've we've had
oh you found it Golem nice so per Golem
Sports here
the Amazon Brazil Amazon okay so it's
Amazon an Amazon thing both the standard
and the deluxe comes with a physical map
dude that's so cool
that's so cool
all right so then DJ Steph had a
question as well other than the Hogwarts
uh what are game what games am I looking
forward to love the channel hey thank
you for the support DJ Steph so I am
we talk about the new Star Wars game
earlier looking forward to that
obviously Zelda really want to play
Zelda
and I have like such a backlog right now
that I need to get through
um star feels another one this year
that I'm interested in
so those are the big four I would say
for this year Hogwarts Starfield Zelda
and the Star Wars game
yeah seeing a couple questions about a
wizard
the ministry of magic
I would love it man I would love it but
I don't think so
I don't think so
uh what do you mean King of the North
what do you mean by intentionally
leaving stuff out like trying to
trying to hide things that
wouldn't like
oh how do I word this like trying to
hide something that's gonna be bad or
give a bad impression or are they making
sure that we don't see everything to
know about the game
because for the second part absolutely I
mean Chandler Woods said they're only
scratching the surface and what they've
shown so far
still need to finish last of us too
oh man that's a hard game to get through
not because it's bad but because that
story man
that story
[Music]
yeah exactly rain man they definitely
want us to find
to to just explore and get lost and find
all sorts of things
thank you for all the new Subs by the
way as well guys I've seen some new Subs
coming in as well oh did I how did I
forget Spider-Man absolutely Nick yes
yes
for sure Spider-Man oh my gosh
I still need to play Miles Morales but I
love the uh
Nico's uh Nico's doing some research on
the left-handed thing right now
I think you're right Nico yeah don't
think there is a left-handed option only
video evidence I could find is from the
2018 leak at 10 seconds oh wow yeah
some people were saying if it's there
then maybe it would be an option
um when you get your wand because like I
mentioned in one of my videos like oh we
didn't see it in the Character Creator
it's probably not there but then other
people were saying well you could do it
when you get your wand I agree could be
then
but I just feel like they would have
shown that by now
but then again I also thought they would
have shown jumping
and then they just randomly one day I'm
like oh yeah it jumpings in here you go
Jake with a super chat as well yes Jake
I watched most of that game that game
was insane did you see that TCU beat
Michigan TCU fan watching this in the
middle of the ocean
wait you on vacation or something
Jake
yeah I watched a lot of that game it was
a really good game
really good game thought Michigan was
going to come back there for a bit but
TCU held on
I hope they win dude I think that'd be
crazy if they pulled the upset nobody's
gonna be giving them much of a chance
but I definitely think they could do it
definitely think they could do it
I hope he isn't over hyping
I mean that's their job as as marketers
you know
their job is to create the hype
or Swim waiting for Chandler to just say
fine and tweeted
we did it's easy yeah we had a big talk
about jumping on the stream before they
revealed it
yeah
we actually used the power of Thor's
hammer right here
to make it happen I posted the clip
about that
all right let's return it to its proper
place there
all right what do you guys say we uh we
hit the 100 likes we hit the 200 likes
let's do a quote Let's do an impression
and then I'll rewind this a bit and
we'll go through this
this last section which I think by the
way is the longest section which is
probably not a good sign for us being
able to fit it all
right into this stream
yeah it was it was the next morning
Ravenclaw Tyrell it was
it was indeed
we may we manifested it
Bobby
with his found the Hogwarts snow globes
on Amazon what
people like already trying to sell the
ones that they got or they just
I wonder if it's like they're officially
gonna make them available
I love that you can name your grab horns
or you can name your creatures you guys
realize we're gonna have to do like a
I gotta come up with something stream
related
to where they're named after some of you
guys
you know that right we gotta do that we
gotta do that
I don't know I don't know what the rules
are gonna be I don't know what the
criteria is gonna be
but we gotta figure out a way to do that
you name your creatures yo Timothy yes
can name the creatures indeed they named
this one Bruce
there you go
so instead of just naming him grabhorn
he can name him Bruce all right here we
go so if you guys are new here whenever
we hit 100 likes in the Stream we do a
random bit of Harry Potter quote trivia
so I will pull up one of the seven books
us editions by the way no one's ever
asked me which which one but yeah us
editions you guys probably assume
correctly
U.S editions all right you know what I
got just the book that I want to look
for tonight
and then you get a point if you can get
the character correct
and you get two points
if you get the book correct as well
what do you win
chat tell them what they win
you win my
support appreciation
and admiration for you
all right so let's kind of skip around a
bit let's pick a chapter we want here
oh dude I already know what chapter I
want
as we get another Super Chat Ryan last
name swimming in games is kind of like
flying but lower
I mean I don't disagree Ryan I don't
disagree thank you for the Super Chat
[Music]
oh dude I gotta pick a page number
[Music]
oh come on
always forget the navigation
on the Kindle app because I don't read
on the Kindle app I read on my I read on
my actual Kindle wait why is there no
table of contents
okay oh yeah here we can just use this
okay this is good this is good
[Music]
you're a wizard Harry
you're a wizard Harry
uh that one's too obvious
too obvious
that one's too obvious
go ninja go with a super chat hey thank
you go ninja no comment
just a little support I appreciate it Go
Ninja
go ninja always a regular
regular here in the Stream hey have a
good night or a good I guess good
morning rain man thank you for being
here
if we can't wait hold on if we can get a
tortoiseshell cat I'll name it retro
oh
well played
well played JP
I can't find the chapter that I wanted
to find
foreign
oh here we go here we go here we go
this is the chapter all right I found
the chapter I was looking for
oh
okay this one this is a good one here
this is a good one
uh Phoenix with another chat outside the
class pulling oh okay okay
all right that's not going to be in this
showcase though we need to open
I was like wait what why am I on the
Hogwarts Legacy page
I do double take for a second there I
clicked on the wrong thing here we go
all right so that would be in the state
of play
which gosh we gotta scroll a ways back
for that one now
and there it was
uh uh that's right-handed
okay right-handed there
okay that that one's right-handed let me
leave it on here for a second
okay maybe this was too long to let it
oh yeah that's is that the one you were
talking about Phoenix
thank you for the Super Chat
but yeah I I uh
did they flip it I mean this this was
the original right here this is this is
on the official Hogwarts Legacy YouTube
page so
the the screenshot that Nico sent me was
definitely it was of this character here
it was definitely a flipped image so you
could see by the Numbers here that this
one's definitely not this one's not
flipped
yeah pretty sure it's always
right-handed all right here we go here's
the quote
I gotta make sure I've got the right
person this one's so obscure
okay yes
all right here we go
okay if you're just joining in you are
just in time for a random bit of Harry
Potter quote trivia I have selected a
random book and a random quote from a
random book in the US version of Harry
Potter
first you can tell me the character who
said it and then you tell me the book
all right so here's the quote
he was a real wizard then
killed me that one did
you fight him boy
here it is again he was a real wizard
then
killed me that one did
you fight him boy
I feel like the last part kind of gives
it away
the last part gives it away if you need
a hint focus on that last part
here it is one more time he was a real
wizard then
killed me that one dude you fight him
boy
we got a Trevor and cursed child
we got a zcm blanket on this one
we got a Hagrid we got an old man and
Goblet of Fire Goblet of Fire old dude
Voldemort killed the ghost of the
caretaker before Kratos book two
Moody says Logan Hagrid no idea what
book
there we go now you got there we go
I feel like once this once one person
got this one I just need to go ahead and
say it yeah Hamza Frank Bryce
Frank Bryce some people said the old man
from book four yeah and then Nico got it
shortly after their Goblet of Fire yeah
so this is in
uh when Harry's fighting Voldemort
priori incantadum occurs
and the one starts basically echoing the
most recent spells so Cedric he sees the
echo of Cedric first and then the next
one he sees is
in this chapter it says old man we know
from Reading earlier that it is Frank
Bryce from
from uh Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire
then if you keep going oh dude I should
have
I should have done the other one Bertha
jorkens this one would have been a good
one don't let go now she cried and her
voice echoed like I always cut out the
little in between her voice echoed like
Cedric's as though from very far away
don't let him get you Harry don't let go
man that chapter you talk about intense
that chapter was so intense
I'll never forget like that fear of the
moment when Harry is
talking about like please let it drown
please let it drown please let it drown
back to Google search it no Professor
Baxter come on now
come on
have a going Christy
I need to do another reread
that was a good one had to think hard
about it yeah I always try to I want to
pick one that
it's not like just
you know
somebody yells or something that would
be totally obscure I want you to have
some Clues
it's funny though even looking back like
all these years later some of them would
be so obvious I actually think the
majority of them would be instantly
obvious just because the way she writes
like the way the characters talk
dude speaking of Kelpie there was
another one right there
there was another one
usually read the book and then watch the
movie then I watched the movie after a
while I forget what happened in the book
oh man
yeah it's been a long time since I've
done a reread I'm definitely due for one
definitely due for a reread okay and
then we also need to do a random Harry
Potter impression
all right so let's see it start throwing
out start throwing out the suggestions
guys
what suggestions do you have for us
tonight
what suggestions do you have
last time we did gosh why do I always
forget the most recent one we did
was it Lockhart did we do Lockhart last
time
I think we did Lockhart
we always get a lot of requests for
Bellatrix
we get a lot of requests for
um
oh who's the other one somebody just
said it
oh a couple dracos Luna
there's a request for Dumbledore
oh uh Rock'em Rakim not sure if I'm
pronouncing it correctly my friend sorry
about that Ollivander was what started
all of this
Ollivander is my go-to that's my best
Potter impression I can't remember which
live stream that was on but you can find
that one if you go back
so I did that one time and then chat
just ran with it and here we are
hey Ryan thank you for the Super Chat my
friend appreciate all the vids over the
past few years well Ryan thank you for
the support dude thank you for watching
and enjoying them
peace we've done we've done Dobby I know
for sure we've done Dobby
you're a wizard Harry
there it was did you guys hear it
I just did it I did Hagrid
pretty good right
that's pretty good one wasn't it
second movie where Ginny asked about her
Jumper in front of Harry oh I feel like
Snape would be a good one
oh dudes that's that's a difficult one
though man Alan Rickman
all right let me and I already know
which one I mean you guys already know
which quote I have to do
okay Snape
bewitch the mind
quote
is this the quote from the book or the
movie
okay yeah this is from the book but I
think they they actually might have used
this word for word
in the movie
we do we do need to do Bellatrix at some
point we definitely need to do Bellatrix
all right hold on drink of water here
first
and then I just have to
have to get into that zone you know of
just like the board
the uninterested
Snape
it's just like this very flat okay
oh wait hold on let's go let's go full
screen Let's Go full screen here give
you guys the
yes RIP indeed to Alan Rickman
very uh just iconic performance
I always want to practice first man oh I
hate I hate you guys hearing the very
first
all right that's how it is though that's
how it is we do it and we roll
I can teach you how to beat no no no
that's not it
I can teach you how to bewitch the mind
and and snare the senses
I can tell you how to bottle Fame Brew
glory and even put a stopper in death uh
not my best not my best
it's a tough one man he's so good and
that voice is just so I can iconic
bottle Fame Brew glory and even put a
stopper in death tell me what are two
young gryffindors like yourselves doing
inside
on a day like this that was better that
that was better right there
and then then hold on hold on we gotta
get we gotta get a
turn to page 394.
foreign
Ninety Four
oh dude
that's the best I could do listen to it
then try it pause more between the words
yeah yeah
someone oh that's a good one too
someone might think you're
up to something
he does speak very slow you're right
you're right
almost
there you go
I think we did hit 300 we don't even
have anything to do for 300.
we don't have anything for 300
by the way we're not there's no way
we're getting through the uh
foreign
there's no way we're getting breaking
this down tonight guys
[Music]
this one's the longest section too right
it goes it runs from about 21
oh yeah it's like a 12 minute
13 minute section there
well now we got a topic next week no
matter what you know even if they don't
release something
[Music]
official we have to come up with a 300
mark
well go ninja I didn't know how long our
hype and expectations conversation I
didn't know how long that would go
I should have known
I should have known I thought we may
only stay on that for you know an hour
or so
but by the time we did all the all the
chats and
welcoming everybody
about the Guitar Hero guitar oh my gosh
Nico I don't even know if I uh
if I have that anymore
I was trying to sell it a few years ago
and I couldn't sell it and then I was
like I should just take this to Goodwill
and I can't remember if I did or not
we that that's right Chris I I should I
mean 100 I should have known
you're currently playing deadly Hallows
on PC zombie Joe oh my gosh
I've never that's one of the few Harry
Potter games I've never played uh but
tomorrow we're gonna resume our Goblet
of Fire Let's Play guys
maybe around 10 a.m Eastern or so over
on Twitch if you're not following us
there
uh it's same name twitch.tv retro record
tour
check us out there
um we'll probably be going live around
10 a.m Eastern or so
playing a little more Goblet of Fire I
actually don't have I might be able to
beat it tomorrow but every time I do a
live stream that means no videos are
getting made
outside of doing more live streams is
that that means no video no YouTube
videos are in the works I mean they are
in the works but I'm not working on them
at that time right
and I really need to get I have one I
want to get out for
um for the combat I really want to get
that one out this week
yeah I saw Arc sorry if I messed up SFO
microtransaction real money purchase
involved so if you go to the official
website the official FAQ they say there
will be no microtransactions in Hogwarts
Legacy now people were a little confused
at first because there is the option to
purchase what they are calling the dark
arts pack
if you buy the deluxe edition or the
very highly priced collectors edition it
includes that dark arts pack
if you do not like if you buy the
standard edition of the game you can buy
that later so it's like
it's like a day one DLC in a way I think
it's only I think it's 9.99
Actually I don't even know if they've
officially said
don't know if they've officially said so
that is an optional purchase
but it appears that that is the only
sort of upgrade and or add-on
no microtransactions though that has
been on the website stated explicitly
for a while
I mean dog dog I'm totally cool with
dog for the stream but I always hate to
bother her if she's like totally asleep
and like right now
actually where is she hold on
foreign
passed out
I do
now if I could find a way to I don't
think this camera swivels all the way
around but if it did
I could do like a doggy camera
wait can't wait for someone to beat
Hogwarts Legacy using a Dance Dance
Revolution Matt oh my gosh are you
trying to give me video ideas Nico
oh my goodness a blue moon with a super
chat a blue moon thank you so much late
thought the whole UI and the rumored
requirement vivarium would have to be
flipped if left hand was optional all
the minis pop up to the right side with
main character standing off center left
for focal point whoa
hey thank you for that comment
let's take a look at what blue Moon's
talking about here
Oh you mean like not these menus but
hold on like this menu right here
that would be kind of weird right
I have to be flipped if left hand well
hold on he's the right oh but you are
right how it does sort of do that
off-centered we've been seeing this with
a lot of games lately like God of War
does this The Witcher that they just did
the the update The Witcher does this as
well Witcher 3
which you can change it back to the
traditional camera but they put the
camera like a little bit or the
characters actually slightly to the left
instead of being right in the center
you're right that would look that would
look so weird if you were in the left
hand you would have to you'd have to
adjust that
very good comment as well
uh Tom are you in the US asking about
the pre-order stuff I haven't seen of
any special stuff us Wise Guys with
pre-orders which is really kind of
unfortunate
I mean usually with big games you'll see
Target and Best Buy and GameStop
they almost always do some sort of
physical
something for a lot of the games
I think Best Buy was like doing I could
be making this up but I feel like I saw
a wand or something but that might have
been a it might have just been a bundle
where they throw a wand in there and
make you pay more for it
[Music]
cats are about to sleep on you and you
can't move
Nico had to oh I don't have that one set
up for nightbot
I do not have that one set up
Hogwarts Legacy
Bop It
Bop It Speed Run I was like b-o-p it
what Bop It speed run
that's right Krista yes
Best Buy was doing I don't know if
they're still doing it but Best Buy was
doing on all editions of Hogwarts Legacy
had a ten dollar gift card for us folks
I saw that uh Hayden yeah I think I
commented on that earlier when you when
you mentioned that I hope so
I hope that's what it means I mean
Kelpies will definitely be in the game
like if they could be able to see them
but we'll be able to ride them and use
them as mounts or you know anything like
that
unlocked memory
oh man
no more no more Quotes no more
impressions
well quotes we might do more quotes but
Impressions I want to keep it I want to
keep it fresh like I don't want to run
out
so like Kelpie is the like water
creature it looks like a horse
they're a creature of lore and Legend
see them in a lot of fantasies
I'm sure we could find a uh actually
there's a couple of different statues
you see appearing in Hogwarts Legacy
with uh the show kelpie
Kelpie I'm just gonna search Kelpie
Harry Potter
so this is on the HP Wiki so they're
aquatic like they live in the water
shape-shifting water demon native to
Great Britain and Ireland
typically appears as a horse able to
shape-shift it's humans
foreign
tastic beasts movies Newt ride rides one
through the water
I do not have any beans but that would
be that would be a good one
oh geez I didn't
you're full screen still oh wait so you
guys didn't get to see hold on
I guess that was the first time I needed
you guys to actually look at
share something on screen with you right
sorry here we go
and then here's the one
that Newt rides
I can't remember which one it is Timothy
can't remember which one
yo all right guys I am uh exhausted man
I had an early start to the day we had
to
took my youngest uh back or my oldest
back to school today he started at
he gets up around 6 50 a.m and then we
did a live stream
and then picked kids up
then we did another live stream so man
I'm gonna I'm gonna try and script out a
video our next video because I
definitely want to get out the combat
one this week and then I'm gonna head
for bed man but we're gonna be up in the
morning for those of you who maybe just
hopped in at the end like Karthik there
sorry Karthik we are just getting ready
to wrap up but um we will be live in the
morning over on Twitch probably around
10 a.m Eastern for some of you that may
be afternoon that may be evening
so maybe I'll see some of you guys over
there
we'll hang out for a bit try and play
through Goblet of Fire I need you there
I need you there chat because that is
not a game
that I want to play through on my own I
need I need you there for the humor
and then hopefully once we knock that
one out
we could jump into uh order the Phoenix
here pretty quickly
see if we can't uh beat that before or
the Phoenix is a little bit longer
Goblet of Fire is not that long or the
Phoenix they open the world back up
um Half Blood Prince so we'll try our
best man we'll see if we can make it
through that was my goal a while ago was
to try and replay all of the main ones
before Hogwarts Legacy launch and so now
I mean we're getting to about a month
away right
getting to about a month away
he rides the Kelpie in the second
fantastic Beast it's right after Jake
and Queenie show up yo white wolf thank
you thank you
yes lumos to everybody thank you all for
being here tonight man this has been
another fun stream appreciate all the
comments man I feel like that was a
really good discussion
on like hype and expectations we had a
lot of different perspectives some
people
talking about how they are intentionally
setting expectations low and trying not
to get too hyped other people have less
of a problem with hype and you know
bounce back and if something doesn't
work out that your hype from no big deal
um I think the biggest thing is like
that blind hype like we talked about but
I I really did enjoy that discussion
guys so appreciate you all being
respectful of everybody
and at the end of the day I'm excited
for the game I'm gonna play it if it
comes out with a one out of 10 review I
I just and I and I hope it's good I hope
it's good if it's not you know we'll
we'll call it and we'll talk about it
and then we'll hope for another one oh
for another one to come along we'll hope
for a patch we'll hope for an update
but yeah we'll see what happens this
week man uh I don't know what the New
Year's gonna bring in terms of
I mean at this point you would think I
don't know how soon Avalanche and WB are
gonna send out review copies I don't
know if they're sending out review
copies
I don't know if we might start getting
preview footage preview discussions if
there's another gameplay showcase if
there's another ASMR still a lot of
things that could take place over the
next what 36 37 days or so here
but I mean it's we're here man we're in
the home stretch in the home stretch at
this point
so I'm so happy you guys are along for
the ride with me um
like I said I won't I don't regret
anything man even if if the game comes
out and it's not what we all hope for
the community the the conversations
we've had you can't replace that man you
can't replace that experience that we've
had together the speculations that we've
had
and we'll just keep hoping you know
we'll keep hoping for the next game
but I think it's good I think it's gonna
be it man I think it's gonna live up to
it
and I think it's gonna do very well
[Music]
oh yeah for sure Blue Moon yeah I'd say
they have a lot of stuff a lot of stuff
prepared and ready to roll
all right guys that's gonna be it for me
thank you all so much for being here yet
again
um hopefully I'll have a fantastic rest
of your week and if you uh are awake
early in the morning or late afternoon
or evening whenever it is for you 10 a.m
eastern time tomorrow we'll be live over
on Twitch hope to see you there guys uh
as always thank you so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]
foreign